my guest today is dr peter borrosian we
happen to have the same last name my
mother's last name is also bogus and
this is a very interesting person we're
going to be talking to today he decides
to troll academia by writing some hoax
papers which maybe we'll get into also
wrote a couple books the book we'll talk
about today is called how to have
impossible conversations a very
practical guide necessary skill to be
able to learn how to do it today and
september 2021 he resigned from his
position at portland state university
citing harassment and a lack of
intellectual freedom dr peter borussian
it's great to have you on thank you and
i'm i'm loving the fact that you
pronounced my last name correctly
[Music]
i listened to a couple of the interviews
they said um
uh uh bogosian uh bojocian it's it's
yeah is an armenian pronunciation and
it's a little tough to do
yeah i tell everybody it rhymes with
explosion just to make it easy explosion
bogotion there you go there you go so uh
peter i mean listen
you're you're one entertaining you're
witty
you're uh one of those uh uh
genius scientist types that knows how to
play the games to uh you know mess with
the other guy but before we get into the
book and before we get into some of the
things that's going on maybe maybe why
don't we talk about why you recently
resigned from your job at portland state
university
yeah i was going to say keep
expectations low for the interview
i resigned from my position at portland
state university because i was hired to
teach critical thinking and ethics and
the university became so woke and so
utterly preoccupied with issues of
gender and race and sexual orientation
that it was not only was it infused in
everything but unless you towed the
party line there were consequences to
that
and so i just i couldn't maintain my
integrity and and teach there anything
and what does that mean what is toad
party line what what does that mean in
your world
in my world it means that there are
certain conclusions that you have to
have about and by the way i actually
share those conclusions but certain
conclusions that people have to have
about you know trans bathrooms or
i should say i share many of those
conclusions not all of them are or
donald trump or
whatever the orthodoxy is they have a
moral orthodoxy of things that that that
they believe
diversity equity inclusion
microaggressions i mean it's a it's all
bundled up together
and the university
became
and is
an indoctrination center and i don't
think kids go there and they get any
kind of an education that you and i
would be familiar with they go in there
and and they're expected to i think the
the wording i use was mimic the moral
certainty of ideologues so these people
are ideologues they have moral beliefs
that they come into the classroom with
and not only do they teach those but
they test those those kids on the
beliefs and they want to back so
it's really a a terrible situation even
if you agree with it
so think about it like this i think that
part of the problem is that people get
too caught up into right thinking and
left thinking and oh you know academia
is 90 actually portland state university
the national scholars association
found that 99 of the faculty and
administrators donated to one political
party get out of here
yeah it's true 99
yeah you can look it up the national
association of scholars and then there's
the oregon association scholars you know
what that party is right of course
they're all trump guys they're all mega
guys
yeah so so the so i i don't necessarily
think that's a problem
but
because you know people can believe
anything they want but remember this is
a public institution yeah right so this
is a public institution
kids are going there they're never
hearing
from people who believe other sides of
the argument
and and it's the whole thing it's just
so disheartening so for somebody that's
not in that world maybe give us a visual
of what that world looks like both for
students who are going there with maybe
opposing ideas as well as a professor
that's in that world
where 99 gives to one party and you're
just kind of trying to and by the way
for for the audience to know this you
were not supportive of anyone in 2016 on
the right as candidates right i don't i
don't think you were even so it's not
like you're one that's a mega team or
anything like that you're just a
professor that's trying to teach there
but maybe give us maybe give us a visual
of what it's like to be in that world
today
sure but not just 2016. i've never voted
for a republican in my life
so i'm not that's very important for the
audience to know that's very important
for the audience to know that yeah
not even am i not a right wing maniac
i'm not even a right one guy period and
so you know i i believe i'm an atheist
as well
uh and i i want to talk about that
in the context of your question so what
does it look like it looks like kids go
into the classroom and they never hear
the other side of the argument
they never hear an opposing view and
they certainly if they do which i doubt
but they never hear it from someone who
believes it why is that a bad thing
if you don't hear an opposing view it's
an indoctrination mill you're going
there to repair it back or regurgitate
you're not teaching people how to think
and then making decisions on their own
let me give you example so i teach i
taught a class it feels freeing to say
that i taught a class an atheism and i'm
a very out and very outspoken atheist
and i would have people come into my
class so i would tell people exactly
what i believe
and then i would have believing
christians who were qualified come into
my class and speak to the kids
and i'll give you an example somebody
wrote after my resignation letter
somebody wrote dr phil smith wrote a
letter to the oregonian he's a
conservative christian he teaches at a
conservative christian university here
in portland oregon and i gave him uh the
whole class
provided that he had a q a so he
couldn't just give a lecture so he gave
a one-hour lecture and answered a
one-hour q a about his best arguments
for the existence of god i didn't say a
thing
and i let the kids decide so the
students themselves make their decisions
and i viewed my job is not only to be
honest with them but to bring in the
best representatives of the other side
and so he wrote and i had no idea who's
gonna do that he wrote a lovely op-ed to
the oregonian which is the local paper
here
and so what does it look like it looks
like only one view is forwarded it looks
like you can't question certain things
that are morally fashionable like equity
and most people by the way they don't
even have the slightest clue what equity
means or diversity or inclusion or any
of these things that have been
that have hijacked uh i mean these
things are now infused in our
institutions and most people have no
idea what they mean
so so you know let's start off with the
basic part woke you hear walk every
everywhere i mean obviously you and i
know what walk means but how would you
define what woke means all right it's
funny you asked that i have a video
series coming out that translates wokish
into plain language and it's a they're
60 second videos basically woke means to
be awakened to the injustice in the
world and the more woke you are the more
you understand that you can never be
woke enough because reality is just
infused with injustice and oppression
everywhere and so
the
part of the communication problem that's
my book how to have impossible
conversations is that people are
speaking past each other particularly in
this context woke people are using
certain words
they don't traffic in the normal
meanings of words when we look them up
in the dictionary like equity would be
another a perfect word that's totally
misunderstood and my kids go to public
school here in oregon or my my my
daughter my son graduated
every email equity equity equity equity
equity equity equity do you know what
equity means
you're asking me ask somebody in your in
in your film crew over there
david what is equity here today
this is the seventh time but what does
equity mean david uh to have a piece of
something yeah like uh no no not equity
of a company equity as an equity uh uh
uh in in uh
in in society equity
oh i would i mean that's i don't know
you wouldn't know in society to be well
that's what they're talking about it's
not equity like you're a piece of the
company all right so this is wonderful
this illustrates the point
the vast majority of people
have no idea what the word equity means
and you know the guy that you're going
to fire after this episode he's he's
absolutely
he's absolutely correct
they've changed the meanings of the word
so equity means to make up for this is
even kennedy's definition uh or a part
of his worldview that feeds into the
definition
to make up for past injustices we need
to future injustices and future and
presence and justices so if people have
been just systematically discriminated
against because they're you know
gay or trans or
black we need to
fix that by discriminating against
people who don't have those
characteristics the other thing to think
about with equity is you want equality
of outcome not a quality of opportunity
that's why the governor of new york for
example has
our ap classes
yeah well they're they're getting rid of
the talented gifted
programs for kids because the idea is
it's an equity-based system it's not
it's the opposite of equality but the
only reason i mention this at all is
because
one of the reasons that woke has made
such inroads is that
in in you know when you ask david most
people don't know what these words mean
and so we're basing policies educational
policies for our kids in k-12 systems
for our judiciary for our media we're
basing these for the aclu the southern
poverty law center all of these things
are now
a value that suddenly sprung into
existence that nobody heard of five
years ago and if they did it was in the
context of finance now who's driving
this though who's driving these
initiatives who's the mastermind behind
this
today because it seems like it's sudden
that this happened the last five ten
years
yeah that's that's correct it started in
the university system and it leaked out
of the university system i i want to say
two things
you remember how shocked you were at the
of people very much so yes okay so so i
think the problem is that people get way
too caught up in oh this is a right left
thing or conservatives or republicans
forget about that forget about that
let's say let's say that that the people
in there were mormons let's say that 99
of the people at a university were
mormons
do you think that that and it was a
liberal arts university yeah
as opposed to you know stem or civil
engineering or math do you think that
those kids would get an as good of an
education from that as they would if
they were intellectual diversity were
there some mormons and some muslims and
some atheists and some christians
of course you're going to have more uh
you know if you have diversity if you
have a uh
sure
and so part of the that's part of the
problem part of the problem is that
you're correct intellectual diversity
benefits our kids it benefits our
democracy it benefits our society
but when you hear the word diversity
which is a very very common word now it
what they mean is two things they mean
intellectual homogeneity they mean an
environment in which everybody thinks
the same and has a certain set of
beliefs but has superficial
characteristics
yeah but but i i guess what i want to
know is do you know who drove these
things like who is driving these
initiatives like yes and then and then
next what's the master plan because
you're not going to be able to push this
for too far there's going to be pushback
by people on the opposing side that
they're just not going to take it
eventually so who's driving this and why
okay so that's a separate question so
we've identified the problem we've seen
how it that
here's what happens so kids go into the
university system yeah they're taught by
people who believe this and these people
are true believers okay not all of them
because they've created a culture of
fear so anybody who speaks up against it
is a bigot is a homophobic racist
misogynist is a nazi in some cases
and so
so they've they have jobs for life it's
called tenure they teach people
you know basically what our moral
conclusions they test them on it
three four five six years later these
kids get out they go to they get out of
the university they go into the
workforce because they have degrees then
they occupy positions of administration
management etc and they bring these
ideas with them the pronoun ideas the
safe spaces the trigger warnings the
microaggressions
the nucleation point where this all
starts is the university system all of
it
i get that but what so why what do you
so let's just say let's just say for
example uh uh uh the first titanic that
was shot the director was a guy that was
a nazi and the producer was hitler and
the hero in the first titanic was a nazi
right and by the way that's a true story
so when that first titanic that came out
the messaging for hitler was to get
people to say what a great hero nazi is
what a great community they are they're
good people and then our guard comes
down and we're more you know receptive
we're more willing to receive
information or influence from those guys
who's behind this and what's the outcome
to do what like i understand if a person
is saying i want to get everybody to
eliminate this so i become the person
they listen to because one day we're
going to do xyz what's the motive
okay so the motive is the idea and you
see this and this is the other thing we
should probably talk about colleges of
education
um
bracket that we'll come back to that
later
the motive is that there is oppression
everywhere there is systematic
oppression
and the evidence for this they don't
really use evidence or really talk about
evidence but a way for sane rational
people to think about it is well why
would they believe this well they
believe this for a few reasons first
they are 100 correct in that that there
has been systemic racism up until fairly
recently it has been embedded in systems
african americans have been treated
horrifically and you know even
uh uh
you know there were miscegenation laws
in this country where people couldn't
marry other people and they were
specifically set up for black men and
white women and those
those have gone away and and even in my
lifetime and i'm 55. so the the main
driver for this is the historical truth
that there were
real genuine systemic oppressions and
that those oppressions still exist and
because they still exist we need to
overthrow the institutions that allow
the perpetuation of systemic injustice
that's why the university is constantly
talking about systemic injustice and
that's also by the way i don't know if
you want to get down this rabbit hole
why they look at the police they want to
defund the police because the police are
the things that they're standing in the
way of the current society that we have
they're upholding the institutions and
the structures that we have and if you
can defund the police then you can
weaken those institutions by allowing
people to revolt and i totally get all
of that everything you said i totally
get i'm aware of everything you just
said right now what i'm asking is
who's the leader for this and what's the
outcome to do what to bring down america
is it to you know eliminate westernized
thinking is it to eliminate capitalism
is it to what who is the voice who's the
person behind it and what's the outcome
okay there is no singular voice okay so
you can think about this like being uh
you know in a weird way like being a
protestant as opposed to being a
catholic there is no pope of this stuff
now there may be bishops or there may be
very influential voices behind this but
there is no leader that's governed
governing things
the outcome is
so even the fact that you ask what the
outcome is means you've thought about it
more than people who have lived in this
space the
one of the outcomes is you see these for
these zones popping up like these
chassis
popping up in seattle and portland i i
really don't think that they've seen
they've thought through what the outcome
is when you overthrow western values in
western civilization and freedom of
speech freedom of speech is a big one
that you have to overthrow freedom of
assembly due process and again they're
looking at the united states as
fundamentally racist and oppressive and
they want to overthrow it now when you
ask me what the outcome is i can't i can
give you my own opinion about the
outcome please
you'll you'll see a new world hegemon
the united states is an empire in
decline that's completely obvious right
now
especially after that which i don't want
to talk about
but but the the fiasco the utter
catastrophe that was afghanistan uh our
our alliances are weakening our economy
is struggling if you look at the the
trade between other other countries in
the united states in the last 20 years
it's shifted primarily to china so if
they think the united states is a bad
boogie man and you should look into the
one belt one road policy in china wait
until they see the new the new hedge
month they're really not going to like
that
who who's who's the uh who wants to see
this happen to america who wants to
because you know a lot of times when you
think about this stuff you you think
about proxy wars you think about how
some of these countries are sitting
there saying listen the way i'm going to
get to america is by pinning xyz against
them so they're playing those games but
who would like to see
america's way of living capitalism all
of that fall who would love to see that
happen
you're a good interviewer really these
are great questions my friend faizal
almutar who heads ideas beyond on
borders he's an iraqi refugee who's come
to this country he's an amazing human
being um he was telling me was spending
time with him was like dog years it's
like seven to one um he was telling me
that the the that many places in the
middle east primarily funded by china
and russia are have
stations dedicated to blm
dedicated to
the divisive madness that's currently
overtaking so basically the enemies of
the united states want to see this
succeed they want to see these
rebellions succeed meanwhile there are
people who
there are countries who are literally
putting their own citizens in
concentration camps and you don't hear a
peep about it from these folks when you
know you'll hear about a gender
imbalance at a conference but when isis
takes literal slaves and we know that we
have the videos from the slave bazaars
when they take yazidi women uh there's
not a peep there's not a protest there's
there's nothing you don't you don't hear
anything about it so
to answer your question directly there
are countries like russia and china and
iran to a certain extent who are
directly funding the blm and and the the
accoutrements are the kind of the um
conceptual drivers for this and then you
have the people on the far left the woke
far left in particular um who really
want to see the end to what they
consider to be an oppressive patriarchal
regime
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
what happens here by the way going back
to your book how to have impossible
conversation so when you're dealing in
an environment in a climate where 99 is
giving to one party and one percent is
given to the opposing party how do you
have those difficult those impossible
conversations
with people from uh
the opposite aisle i mean how do you
have those conversations yeah that's
another really good question it's
actually really easy to have those
questions that once somebody when i
taught in prisons i did my dissertation
and i taught prison inmates how to think
through moral questions
and i
pulled from the history of western
philosophy you know
questions like what does it mean to be
what is justice and
she's so many questions
you know can you be unjust towards
yourself and what does it mean to be a
good man
when people will talk to you
already
even even if you think the the the gulf
or the divide is so great the moment
someone's talking to you
that's that's great um those
conversations are more far more possible
than you think
far more possible the problem is when
they won't talk to you and that's the
situation which we have now
these
the folks who participate in this
ideology they don't
um buy into the norms of civil society
they don't buy into reason discourse
evidence and this is really important
for your audience to understand
so if if if let's say that you and i
want to figure out a problem let's say
we want to figure out you know we've
heard from armenians for example and and
armenians are claiming
that uh they're pulled over by the
police
at radically disproportionate rates than
non-armenians
you and i would sit down and say all
right man
we got to figure this out how we're
going to do this and we'd say okay well
we're going to look at the the the body
cams of people we're going to every time
someone calls in we're going to see if
they have an ian or the y end which
anybody doesn't know that's your mean
last
and we're gonna and then we're gonna
we're gonna kind of study this somehow
we're gonna figure out you know we're
gonna do a survey data whatever however
we're gonna do it okay that's how sane
rational people go about figuring stuff
out
these folks don't buy
the traditional tools that we would use
to solve problems reason
evidence
epistemic adequacy which basically means
you know knowing what you're talking
about
what they would do is so they believe
this is this uh aubry lloyd's the
master's tools cannot disable the
master's house the master's house is the
current system we have and it's
patriarchy racism oppression
so what built this this is their
thinking like what built the system well
evidence reason
you know
science to a certain extent
all these things so you can't disable
the patriarchy you can't disassemble it
through evidence and reason you have to
use something else like you have to
you know rip down statues you have to
get to tear stuff down you have to
whatever whatever
the the particular
brand of lunacy is you have to defund
the police
um you you have to
you have to make it so that the system
in place is just is disabled
was that clear you have to do it so the
system in place is
disabled uh i i again i fully get that
for me it it uh keeps going back to
the outcome of what you're trying to do
like you know if you look at different
empires on how they fell okay iran
romani from the outside was sending
tapes in okay those tapes eventually
caught you know they they started
creating some momentum people were you
know dubbing the tapes passing it down
to other people and the messaging was
the shy is too rich look at the
celebration he put at the 2500 years
that's your money if i was running iran
i would give that back to you this is
not fair look how bad the conditions are
let's revolt it's worth it we can take
them out you know look what savaka is
doing to innocent people etc etc boom
they take them out the outcome was
get rid of shah because they painted
shot to be the puppet to the west
and you know you know nothing's really
going to happen for 40 some years later
still here so that's one i'm trying to
i'm trying to get a little bit deeper to
see what you have there let me see if i
can
again this is complicated let me see if
i can give you the the goal what they
want is a utopia
now
they they want so so this is okay so
this is
this is the next level of this so i'm
gonna try to explain it it's very
complicated if it's unclear you tell me
it's not it's my explanation not your
understanding
part of the assumption going into this
whole thing
is that they have certain assumptions
they don't like what they call grand
narratives grand narratives are
sweeping explanations to explain things
like christianity is a grand narrative
biology is a grand narrative
communism is even a grand narrative
and so
at root of this is a biology denialism
that's why you see so many of these
folks deny evolution for example
so
when you
if
if you're trying to
okay this is so complicated okay
every this is the way they think every
disparity
of outcome
is
the system is responsible for that and
the system is responsible for that
because it's inherently racist that's
again why they want to get rid of the
talented and gifted program so every
disparity in outcome is due to a racist
system
so it couldn't possibly be to any
cultural upbringing or maybe it is but
it's certainly not due to biology
so if you can change the systems
you can
engineer an outcome
you can engineer the outcome that you
want to engineer which
in one word to answer your question is
utopia but you can't get to the utopia
if you have the existing systems
and part of the and part of the reason
for that is because they're biology
denialists
they deny
basic rudiments of biology
so
um
okay now i'm gonna get in trouble this
is where i get in trouble
um
so there are certain things that we
can't talk about in society let me throw
out let me throw out something
what what if that what is one of the
commonalities among nobel
prize laureates um who have a
disproportionate number of winners been
left
and academia
no they've been scientists oh i see what
you're going okay jews they've been jews
but not only have they been jews i was
just talking to brian keating about this
uh he's the guy who uh he's
uh the physicist into the impossible um
it's much easier to talk about this with
people who actually share those identity
markers than those who don't like you
and you and i have a lot of identities
in common i'm sure
um
but it's not just jews
it's it's not sephardic jews it's
ashkenazi jews
and it's not even just ask an aussie
jews it's asking aussie jews that are
from specific regions in like poland
then germany breslau region
so
why would that be and how do we know
that well um
this is complicated stephen pinker the
psychologist from harvard writes about
this one of the ways we learn about this
is we look at identical twins separated
at birth and then
again this is a whole i don't know this
is the whole thing is complicated so the
mean iq is is a hundred the average iq
is a hundred
if you look at identical twins separated
from birth okay so if you just pluck two
people out of the population the
difference in iq would be eight but
identical twins separated by birth would
have a difference in iq of four
that tells you
that there's something biological to the
iq
but
if your starting assumption is that
there are nothing it
that
biology doesn't determine cognition it
doesn't determine iq etc etc then you
have to come up with a reason for that
and one reason you could say is well uh
that's racist or the tests are faulty or
the tests don't test what you think they
test or what whatever reason that you
wanted to
to come up with by the way
parenthetically this is extraordinarily
interesting
okay
so what happens is
that idea itself is morally fashionable
because people teaching it
are basically on the woke left and they
have been for years
and so what what happens as a
consequence of that is
that we now have a generation of people
who don't think that the iq measures
would psychologists say g or general
intelligence that it doesn't measure
what people think that it measures
right it does maybe it doesn't measure
anything at all so we have all these
people now thinking the iq is bogus
can i tell you a cool story go for it
i don't think i've ever told anybody
this before so um
my mentor told me this story this is
absolutely fascinating to me
so
my mentor
his name was frank wesley he was
interned in buchenwald he was picked up
by chris uh by the nazis on on krystal
knocked
and he he
became a psychology uh professor
fascinating man fascinating history
he told me and he was a behaviorist
and a behaviorist is someone who
believes that you can control
behavior by looking at it in terms of
stimulus and response
oversimplified but basically so he told
me this unbelievable story
so there was a kid and i think if memory
serves me correctly this kid was in
washington
and he kept punching his face like this
and they tried everything but they
couldn't get this kid to stop punching
his face
and so what they did was they put
electrodes on his arms and when he
brought his hand up there
they they zapped him
it only took two zaps
on um
two zaps for this kid to stop punching
himself in the head
now
frank had this on
um
on on vcr i don't know if any of your
you were
maybe older than older than you but vcr
is like these analog tapes then they're
not digital
and so
i don't know maybe you should i don't
will people even know what it is vcr is
yeah okay okay so so um
so
the the tape had a a glitch in it so he
sent the tape down to the av or whatever
i t places that fixed it
and they i the the place reported the
tape for having content which um
displayed human cruelty it basically
violated a rule
and so they literally cut the piece of
the tape out so you don't see the the
guy uh punching him but you can see the
electrodes and they also cut out the
section that even explained that
so
we're so that knowledge is then lost to
the rest of humanity because it's viewed
as cruel and whether or not you think it
should be lost that's that's another
story yeah
but the idea is that
you can see how our institutions based
upon values that people have determine
the outcome of what people think is true
there was just something that came out
recently about dog training i can't
remember the name of it but you can put
it on your screen that that you know uh
there shouldn't be any punishment a big
of a dog i can't remember the name of it
but uh
plus said you know there's dog training
shouldn't have any punishment at all it
should be our reward okay so that's
ideological that's not evidence-based so
what happens now is the the people for
example in the behaviorists with the kid
punching himself in the head or woke
ideology or microaggressions or any of
this stuff all of that is then
fabricated it's it's it serves it lives
in service to an ideology and not in
service to the truth and then people
take this information and they they
believe it because they think it's true
and then they get out and they they
bring it to the workplace they talk
about it to their friends so the whole
society is harboring some delusions
about things
does that make sense yes it does yes it
does so let me ask you does this become
the story that you told is that
selective
that's not selective hearing it's a
selective teaching is it selective
influence is it controlling
a part of the information to
help you come up with a different
conclusion and how often is that done
you know in accutane academia
well it's it's done
the reason it's done is because people's
moral minds override their rational
minds now
look i'm not saying that
i mean
it's there's a reasonable conversation
to be had and i'm not really sure which
side i fall on you know about dr
mengele's experiments on jews and should
those you know when he broke bones over
and over again should we look at that
uh
and use that to benefit humanity or is
it it was just so utterly monstrous it
shouldn't even be considered
we can have that conversation but the
point is that
we're tr we're all doing our best to try
to create systems here that are fair and
just
and
although they're not trying to create
systems that are fair they're trying to
create systems that are equitable but
we're trying to do the right thing and
when you try to do the right thing
often you're you're living in service to
an ideology your moral mind is
truth is no longer your north star right
so so the the purpose of the institution
hasn't become defined what's true it's
to replicate the dominant moral
orthodoxy
does this strategy work to work today
meaning like the direction they're going
with vocism with equity with gaslighting
we're confusing the hell out of all of
us and pinning us against each other
is this a proven strategy long term
because you know you're seeing some what
you're starting to see as well is
how people on opposite sides are sitting
there saying
i disagree with my party what they're
doing here i also disagree with my maybe
we got more things in common than before
i'm not sure this approach
maybe it worked 200 years ago maybe it
worked a hundred years ago do you think
an approach like this is going to work
today in america
it's it's i'm shocked by the question
it's already worked it's astonishing
long term you think long term this is
sustainable yeah long term no i don't
think so yeah i agree yeah in fact it it
it is utterly it is utterly impossible
to sustain itself long term you would
need a kind of tyranny
you know you would need to up and
totally up and free speech but it's
interesting if you look at surveys for
example from the foundation for
individual rights and education yeah
it's great dana's organization one in
four college students believe that
violence is acceptable to college
lecturers
this the that's an astonishing to guest
lecturers who come in it's an
astonishing number of people who don't
feel think 40 don't feel they can ask
questions or
ask difficult questions if it's on a
moral topic i mean it's across the board
we're seeing people we're seeing this
this effect
incredibly successful in the short term
but not successful i don't think so
because if you think about what happened
in in canada toronto when the university
of toronto i think it was when they came
out with the trends here's what we're
going to be doing and the controversy
with jordan peterson
let's take that out let's say that event
doesn't take place do you think jordan
peterson is as famous as he is today
think about it take that event out who
is jordan peterson so so i think what
they're also doing is they're giving
birth to jordan peterson to gatsa to you
know people like yourself to the rogans
of the world they're they're getting
others to say to a russell branded the
world or bill maher of the world to some
people that maybe they would have never
given birth to they're like wait a
minute this just doesn't make a lot
of sense to me i'm backing off because i
no longer agree with you because we're
not on the same page so i just don't
think the long term
this approach of bullying is sustainable
because to what what is the power of a
free thinker if you think about a free
thinker what what's their dna they
question things they're curious
and they typically
don't stop at no they don't stop at mind
your own business so they don't do well
with bullies they typically
stand up to bullies and eventually
bullies can bully the regular guys
they're like okay i don't want to have
any conflict but until you face a free
thinker like okay i don't like messing
with this guy he's different so you're
going to give a lot of birth to free
thinkers like jordan peterson over the
next decade because i just don't think a
lot of the free thinkers are going to
stand alone stand stand there and just
say you know we're going to take all the
bullying from you i see that not taking
place
no no no that's right and jordan has
done an amazing job of that my my friend
gatt has done an amazing job of that
so the question is how do we empower
other people to stand up and fight back
against this ideology that's one one
question
not only is this not sustainable listen
nobody likes living like this
nobody likes being petrified of what
they can say yeah but people have been
canceled because they were bullies in
grade school
are you freaking kidding me they were
bullies when they were six and now that
you're you're denying them employment or
you're complaining to their advertisers
that they're you know white supremacist
which doesn't even have anything to do
with it
and so
not only do people not like living like
this but the question is
what damage is this going to do to our
institutions in the short term i mean
it's already done a tremendous amount of
damage by the way
you were talking about nobel prize
earlier so i went and looked up when you
were talking uh to see who's won over
the years uh armenian uh uh bengali four
people armenian one apparently chinese
twelve people hokey on one jewish i'll
get to jewish last
pashtuan nobel is one punjabi is two
tamil is three tibetan is one and how
many you think is jewish based on what
you said what do you think the number is
well the jews aren't even two percent of
the population so
uh
significantly
198 people
of nobel prize laureates by ethnicity
198 i mean the numbers are staggering
and another article just came out
yesterday that uh by uh
they had goran hansen head of royal
swedish academy of science sciences
said they want people to win because
they made the most important discovery
we will not have gender or ethnicity
quotas says top scientists interesting
good for them yeah well i mean that's a
that's a merit-based system and again so
so the question is
two questions one drill down the data
and you'll find that they're
overwhelmingly ashkenazi jews and
they're overwhelmingly from certain
region region of the planet but the
question is well why is that the case
that gets us a little far afield in our
in our topic but i brought that up
because
um you you can't say that it's if you're
on the woke left you can't say that
biology has anything to do with it and
it's interesting so since we're having
this conversation let's just let's have
this conversation let's be honest about
this so
somebody was teaching i'm not going to
name the name of the institution you can
probably guess what it is but somebody
was teaching a philosophy of race class
at that institution and um
it was fascinating to me i remember i i
was sitting across from this person and
um
i just wanted to say well what about
this what about this what about this
like and this is way outside my area but
i didn't do that because if i did that i
would have been accused of racism or
bias that's not saying i believe that
there are valid biological races or
that's not saying anything it's just
saying that there's a kind of
there's even something called the bias
response team that you can report people
to if you think that they they have any
bias in them whatsoever
and
many i think over well over 200
institutions academic institutions have
bias response teams but it would seem to
me like you know what why do certain
people get tay sachs and other people
don't why do certain people get sickle
cell and other people don't but you
would think that the the purpose of that
class would be to to really take a look
at what race is what it means etc how
it's come to be as an idea but one would
also think to be really honest about
that you'd have to at least talk a
little bit about
uh you know race realism or i'm even
hesitant to talk about these things but
you would think that the
that
you would have to
give students
um
the best voices from all sides of the of
the issue and if you're not comfortable
doing that then don't offer the class
right don't offer the class
but the other thing that's interesting
about that is you would think that the
qualifications for that person they
should have some biological
qualifications master's degree in
biology phd in philosophy i don't know
what it would be
but it would seem like that that's
important let me tell you may i tell you
one one more quick story go forward yep
so i was at a um at a a talk
and i'm not going to name the university
the university where i used to teach and
somebody said that he wanted to
um
to offer a native american
uh class a class in native american
philosophy
somebody in the audience said you know
uh
i'm not i'm not really
i think this is a wonderful idea i love
your presentation but i'm not really
comfortable questioning
the as a colonizer i'm not really
comfortable asking questions about
things i disagree with in the philosophy
and and the presenter said yeah you know
i'm i agree i'm not not comfortable
either and the purpose would just be
to teach the ideas and to sit with them
and and to learn learn from them
listen
the tool of the trade from socrates on
is counter example is question
is
challenge
there is no nobody gets a free pass if
you want to put native american
philosophy into the philosophy
department great i think that's the best
idea that wonderful idea
and
we do we we don't give it special
treatment we give it the same treatment
that we give the french the germans the
africans everybody gets the same
treatment we can generate counter
examples we can find flaws or what we
think are problems in the argument and
we move on
but the but but here's the other problem
am i really going to be the guy who says
you know what since we're not going to
do that we shouldn't offer it no i'm not
going to be the guy because that's easy
that's fun as well
that's right no it has nothing to do
with me hating native americans
it i no it's if you want to offer a
course
that has to play by the same rules as
every other class
i keep going back to the outcome i keep
going back to trying to find out what
the outcome is but you know what if you
don't mind for some of the audience that
doesn't know uh what you and your
partner did with the hoax papers do you
mind sharing a couple of those story on
what you guys are with the hoax papers
yeah so let's let's put a pin in the the
outcome
the outcome is to destroy the system to
create a new utopia because it's not
biology that's standing in the way it's
all it's it's the patriarchy that's
standing in the way and systemic racism
and if we can only destroy the system we
can create some kind of a utopia history
doesn't favor those guys
history just doesn't favor quite a bit
of damage fantastic yeah they've done it
they've done a great amount of damage to
society no question about it
yeah um okay so the hoax papers so we i
i noticed that this stuff being in the
belly of the beast i noticed that this
madness
i i used to follow on twitter uh a um
a uh twitter feed called new real peer
review and they would tweet out the
actual articles from peer-reviewed these
are scholarly presentations
and i i would say like these are just
can i swear on your show sure go for it
if these are insane yeah these
are batshit crazy
and alan sokol who subsequently became a
friend of mine published a fake paper
in the late 90s
and that paper was in a postmodern
journal and he wanted to expose the the
kind of
quote-unquote scholarship in the journal
is just bogus and so he used gibberish
to do so and he talked about meaningless
things
so
i thought well let's let's do it do a
circle style hoax so
my buddy and i wrote down wrote a a
paper and and you can link to it in the
description here the conceptual penis is
a social construct
and we argued
we argued among other things in that
paper that you know penis is responsible
for climate change and it was gibberish
and
and they
it's a really funny paper man you should
read it it's really funny uh
uh but i'll let i'll let you and your
audience decide if it's funny or not
um and so um
people went crazy they they they lost
their minds and the point of this was to
show that look you know these journals
are publishing stuff they're publishing
you know if we said the same thing about
vaginas it never would have gotten etc
so you know a lot of people had some
very legitimate criticisms of of the
journal and
they said you know this paper does not
do what you think it does if if you want
this paper if you want to show that
gender studies in particular but
anything with the word studies in it is
just publishing dangerous nonsense you
have to do this with better journals you
have to do this with more journals they
gave us a roadmap
you know and so i said to to my buddy
okay well dude let's just do this
they've told us exactly what we need to
do let's do it he said all right so uh
over the course of the year the three of
us wrote 20 papers the wall street
journal caught us which ironically was
because the paper about dog rape we
claim that
uh dog parks are petri dishes for canine
rape culture and we need to leash men
like we need leash dogs and we looked at
it from black feminist criminology that
paper won an award get out of here well
it's totally serious it won an award but
anyway the wall street journal busted us
and we for sure we would gotten more
than seven papers published and these
pokers were just insane they were just
like you know a fat bodybuilding that
fat people should go into professional
bodybuilding spaces and display their
fat and and non-competitive ways they
should be given equal time
so we did a whole bunch full-on troll i
mean this is a full-on troll job
well it's even well the point i mean we
translated it was mind conf and and i
mean you know
about
remediating uh transphobia by why you
know why we asked the question why don't
men like things shoved up their asses uh
you said i could speak uh
and we came up with this whole thing
about you know their transphobic
but anyway anyway the the the point the
point of this is that we were trying to
make the point that um that there are
bodies of literature producing nonsense
this is untethered to reality
they're teaching this in to the kids as
knowledge
um
and you want to know frankly what's
responsible for this is that people
think that they know things right and
they think they know things because it's
in peer-reviewed journals that people
with phds teach them
no these are the musings of ideologues
that's what that is these are the moral
impulses that people discharge and
journal journals and teach kids and they
have the audacity to test them on that's
why i told you that story about my
mentor
and having that thing because what
happens is anything that doesn't fit the
narrative is just removed from the
curricula right so we have everybody
thinking the same thing oh
you know iq is bogus there it's just no
we have everybody thinking the same
thing about sexual orientation and race
and look here's the the rub to this we
need to study these issues
we need to but we need to do that
rigorously and we need to do it honestly
and we need to
we need to have we need to try to
falsify what these claims are not to try
to prove them
and if we want to make any steps forward
as a society if we want to build better
institutions if we want to treat people
more kindly and more compassionately and
more humanely that
has to be because not because we just
started making up but because we
tried our best we forwarded hypotheses
and we used the tools of science to see
if those hypotheses stood up to scrutiny
that's how we make a better society so i
gotta
i got a call the other day from a guy in
hollywood who says some of the guys from
cnn and fox
are uh wanting to leave and start a a
media company and they'd like to talk to
anyways we're having a conversation
together right now follow up they want
the company to be
50 owned by people on the right 50 owned
by people on the left right that's what
they want to do and let's go and see you
know how this is going to look when we
run the company so everything gets
debated non-stop
how should these papers be judged
where somebody from both sides can sit
there and you know
not just trash it but be almost like the
devil's advocate to
you know show some uh of you know leaks
in the argument and and if we don't have
that today what is the current process
of getting the paper published well
that's that's what the two things one
that's what the reviewers are supposed
to do the reviewers are supposed to find
flaws in the argument who are the
reviewers
well the reviewers are literally experts
in their field
people who have been deemed experts in
their field review the papers that's how
the peer-reviewed process works you have
the
i don't know if they're world's leading
scholars but but bona fide scholars who
have published in scholarly journals
read over your piece and then make
recommendations and in most cases they
made recommendations that made our
papers more crazy so we took those
recommendations and we wrote them right
into the paper
the second thing about the media
enterprise is we are in desperate need
of that my my unsolicited advice to your
friend is i would definitely not do it
50 50. the problem with that is that 50
50 will leave at other voices there are
many votes like andrew yang wants to
make the forward party i'm actually
speaking on friday but um
you know there there are you supported
them you supported them in 2016 i think
right you were that's correct yeah
that's correct there are you know greens
and libertarians etc
there are many alternatives uh and my my
fear is that if you just had a 50 50
split
you'd just be replicating in a sense the
same thing over and over you know the
famous jon stewart when uh or when he
went on tucker carlson you know you
don't want to be that guy who replicates
a kind of division you my thinking would
be you want genuine intellectual
diversity you want to present the the
best arguments on both sides but you
want to do so in in a certain way that
um
that
i just think it needs to be more
thoughtful than 50 50. although i i'm
very sympathetic with that that um that
impulse yeah i think i think as long as
we go in the direction we can see
opposing sides sincerely having a fair
platform to argue each other and the
audience makes a decision for themselves
i think we win i you know like when
you're saying 99 is one side one percent
the other side who the hell is winning
nobody's winning there and that's what
we don't have right now right we don't
kids aren't seeing that they're not
seeing those conversations modeled for
them they're they're not uh they feel
uncomfortable asking questions they
don't even have anybody who
who disagrees with the other side and if
anybody is wondering about that here's a
litmus test question you if you know a
gender study student ask them this do
they know what martha knew bombs
criticism of judith butler is
i don't want it's too very inside
baseball but the idea is that they will
not know it and they will not know it
because they're not taught other sides
of the issue these are advocacy
institutions they're activist
institutions that push certain points of
view so what's the long-term solution
let's wrap it up with that what is the
long-term solution what can the average
guy do and if not the average guy
somebody who is an influencer and is
worried about coming out what can he
or she do
uh short-term and long-term okay so a
few things the first order of business
i'm coming out with a uh a series of
videos i now have a sub stack my last
name is bogojian b-o-g h-o-s-i-m
borosian uh i have a um
i'm on twitter at bogosian and so i
my goal is to give people a front row
seat in the culture war to re-anchor us
in reason and evidence and civility and
argument and basically not being dicks
to each other and how do we do that so
the with one of the things that the
average person can do as they move
forward is they can listen they need to
figure out what people mean by certain
words if you don't have that that's not
academic that's just having a
conversation with someone like what do
you mean by equity again most people
have no idea what it means minoritized
houseless knowing people don't know what
those words mean and we hear them
increasingly
i would suggest that you that people who
want to do something about this listen
learn you can read the book cynical
theories by helen pluckrose
and james lindsey that's like a master
level course and all of this stuff it
explains this in detail but
the other thing you can do is you can
document you can go to meetings you can
record look at the whatever the laws of
the state are
um but you know take pictures of of
material and then you can do what jody
shaw did you can just go to youtube and
and
post those videos to youtube because
we need to let people know what's
happening the other thing if you want to
do you can be more involved and you can
actually like i have projects i need
help in like you know not financially
involved you know like we need a lawyer
right now and we need you know
we just need people to help us and there
are other organizations that astronomy
is doing wonderful work so
that you can get involved and get
involved in a way that that makes you
feel comfortable but the most important
thing in all of this is you have to be
forthright in your speech and you have
to be honest when you talk to people and
you have to know that one of the
consequences of you being forthright and
honest in your speech is that you will
lose quote-unquote friends but those
people will never your friends to begin
with if your friends aren't if your
friendships aren't based on virtue
they're just they're i wouldn't say
they're but
they're not what you think they are
now the answer your last question what
we can end on this what do we do
in terms of the context of the
university system we have to make truth
the primary
um
goal and value of the institution
the moment the truth is no longer part
of the institution it becomes a kind of
ideology factory uh whatever the
ideology is today it's wokism who the
hell knows what it's going to be
tomorrow nobody knows what it's going to
be but it has to be true and it has to
have intellectual diversity and
for example if you're donating to your
alma mater i would stop
in
basically every university because these
aren't the same institutions that you
went to there are new institutions
emerging
yep one is in austin i'll be a part of
that uh and there and those are based on
genuine free speech open inquiry
and people actually having conversations
with each other but truth is the goal so
as long as truth is the north star
you're good to go well brother it's been
great having you on i really enjoyed
listening to we're going to put the
links to uh
your book below the how to have
impossible conversations as well as the
paper you recommended but i really
enjoyed this man thanks for coming on
thanks man where do you live let's have
a few drinks come on down fort
lauderdale come on down here south
florida we'll have a good time together
i love that i totally love that man i'm
looking forward to it all right thanks
bro take care buddy honestly i lost
count how many topics we covered but but
it was a lot of stuff that we went
through curiosity what stuck with you do
you agree with him if you do give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and if you enjoyed this interview two
other interviews i think you'll enjoy
one is with gadsat which was not only uh
informative it was entertaining you're
going to lab or with anarchist michael
malus complete different angle but it
makes sense if you listen to him as well
so click if you want to watch us if not
watch cats take care everybody bye
[Music]